the people pushing this are the tech
companies Google and Facebook I said why
would Google and Facebook push this well
Google is being threatened via YouTube
shorts with Tick Tock Facebook is being
threatened on Instagram by Tick Tock but
Facebook wants more than that Facebook
would love to be able to ban telegram
because people would use WhatsApp this
is all blatant cronyism disguised as a
bipartisan Bill to try to stop the CCP
from mining our kids data we should try
to do something to fix that make them
onshore it sell it to an American
company the idea of giving the federal
government censorship powers of a social
media app I think it's a really bad idea